TO THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- POSSIBLY THE LAST
ONE OF THE YEAR. MY NOTES SAY
THAT WE HAVE A HUNDRED SEVENTY
BILLS. REALLY HOPE THAT IS THE.
ALL RIGHT THAT'S OKAY THAT'S
OKAY- WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. THE DALLAS
PRESENT BIGELOW RIGHT BRIAN
CALDERON CARRILLO CHAU YEAH
ALLEN DAVIES FONG GABRIEL
EDUARDO GARCIA STONE. CORK YEAH
ROBERT RIVAS WEBER. RIGHT TO
WORK THANK YOU MR STONE FOR
FILLING IN- FOR MISTER LEVIN
TODAY- MISSILE YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT TO MR MCGUIRE'S BILL SB.
EIGHTY ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR CORK IN A
SECOND BY. MYSTERIOUS YOU MAY
LIKE LAST. ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND GO AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY LISTED. WITNESSES SO WE'RE
GONNA BIDE BY SOME VERY STRICT
RULES WHEN WE GO TO THE PHONES
OF THE OPERATORS THERE IT IS
JUST SOMEBODY'S NAME THE
ORGANIZATION IF THEY HAVE ONE
AND IF THEY SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL THAT IS ALL WE'RE
TAKING IF YOU GO BEYOND THAT WE
WILL CUT YOU OFF. OPERATOR.
CORRECT WE ASK THAT YOU. COOL
CAN I GET THE FUNDS FOR ANYBODY
ON THE PHONES. LABIODENTAL HE
WOULD- LIKE YOUR LINE- PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND NOBODY TO
AT THIS TIME WONDERFUL WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
I SEE NO DISCUSSION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. WHAT'S OF COURSE
I'LL IS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HERE. NO ALL RIGHT NOBODY IN
THE GALLERY THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
MISTER BIGELOW DO HAVE A
QUESTION FOR MR ALI YEAH. WE
ARE NOTICING THAT NUMEROUS
CHANGES RELATIVE TO THE
FISHERIES ARE CONSISTENT WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DENTURES CRAFT OUTSCORES CAN
YOU KIND OF EXPLAIN WHAT THOSE.
CHANGES ARE. THANK YOU THAT'S
WHAT I WANTED CLARIFICATION ARE
WONDERFUL- FOR THOSE WATCHING-
WE DO NEED WE DO HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY POLL IN FISCAL
BILLS AND THAT'S WHY WE DID
THIS BUT OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS ON THE SPELLING WITH
THAT IT GETS OUT ON AND A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. WE ARE. ADJOURNED
EXISTENCE HUNDRED SEVENTY BILLS.
M. F. DANCERS THE PRINTED TO.